my name is Jeremy mahalik and I'm going
to be today addressing the question our
federal policies targeting the right
plug-in vehicles I'm an associate
professor in the Department of
Engineering and public policy and the
department of mechanical engineering and
I direct the design decisions laboratory
and the vehicle electrification group
and I'm also a member of the green
design institute and the center for
energy and climate decision-making and
there are members from each of these
groups that were involved in the
research i'll talk about today so to
understand the benefits of plug-in
vehicles we first have to understand the
different types of electrification
possibilities we're all familiar with
conventional vehicles that run on
gasoline and four years we've added
access to hybrid electric vehicles like
the Toyota Prius which still run
entirely on gasoline but have a small
battery pack on board and a small
electric motor to help improve fuel
efficiency newer vehicles like plug-in
hybrid electric vehicles have somewhat
larger battery packs that can be plugged
into the wall to charge up and store
energy that can be used to propel that
vehicle partially using the electricity
from the battery pack and when that runs
out switch to gasoline for longer trips
this is like the Chevy Volt and finally
battery electric vehicles like the
Nissan Leaf have no gasoline backup and
rely only on electricity stored in the
battery pack so they need a much larger
battery pack in order to obtain a
reasonable range as we move from right
to left on this chart we require larger
battery packs in order to make the
vehicles functional now all else being
equal adding more batteries to a vehicle
is going to allow the vehicle to drive
longer distances using electricity
instead of gasoline and that's a good
thing however these batteries are very
expensive in fact they can be the most
expensive part of the vehicle they're
all so heavy and lugging around that
extra weight can reduce fuel efficiency
and the production of the batteries
themselves have implications for the
environment and so to know which is
better on balance requires an analysis
of the entire life cycle of the owning
and operating a vehicle we see on the
right that different automakers are
taking different strategies in terms of
how to size the batteries
vehicles and the federal government is
encouraging automakers to put larger
batteries and vehicles the stimulus
package of 2009 gives a 2500 dollar tax
credit for vehicles that have at least
four kilowatt hours worth of battery
which is about the size of a plug-in
version of the Prius and they give up to
7,500 dollars for vehicles with a 16
kilowatt hour battery pack which is the
size of a Chevy Volt so the government's
saying the more batteries you put on the
vehicle the more taxpayers should
subsidize that vehicle and this leads me
to believe that policymakers must
believe larger battery packs are better
in some way provide more environmental
benefit and we wanted to test and see if
that is true so what we looked at was
first how much can electric vehicles
help we know that electrical vehicles
are going to reduce gasoline consumption
which addresses dependency on foreign
oil and other costs associated with
consuming gasoline and we also know that
electric vehicles are going to change
the emissions profile associated with
driving with electric vehicles will have
fewer of the emissions that are
associated with gasoline production and
combustion but will have more of the
emissions associated with producing
electricity and producing gasoline again
on balance to know what's better we need
to do a full assessment from cradle to
grave so this is what we did considering
not just tailpipe emissions but
emissions from refineries power plants
and even upstream emissions from things
like mines and we looked at air
emissions things like costs to human
health respiratory problems that people
get from air pollution damages to
agriculture and infrastructure and
climate change and then we also looked
at issues with petroleum consumption by
consuming petroleum I also cause other
costs to the US economy one of those is
supply vulnerability the more gasoline
would consume the more sensitive our
economy is in the case that the supply
of oil were to be disrupted number two
is what we call them an OP Saini premium
meaning the more oil we consume the more
we raise the price of oil in the world
market and therefore we pay more for all
the remaining barrels of oil that we
purchase
and the third is military spending and
the question here is if we were to
reduce or eliminate gasoline consumption
from personal transportation how much
would we expect the government to reduce
military spending in the world as a
result and there's a lot of details in
this study but among the most important
results are shown here what you're
seeing is on the x-axis is the size of
the battery pack in vehicle and the blue
dots represent some of the vehicles we
tested HEV is hybrid electric vehicle
like a Prius phed plug-in hybrid
electric vehicle with size for a 20 or a
60 kilometer battery pack that's again
similar to the plug-in version of the
Prius and the Chevy Volt respectively
and then a battery electric vehicle we
looked at one with a hundred and fifty
mile range about double the range of the
Nissan Leaf but a little bit more
realistic as a potential primary vehicle
and the y-axis shows you the dollar
value of all of those air emissions and
oil displacement benefits that I
mentioned the red line is the current
federal tax credit which shows as the
battery pack gets larger there's more
taxpayer subsidy and if you look at the
blue dots what they show is our best
estimate of these air emissions and oil
displacement benefits are relatively
small compared to that photo tax credit
but maybe more importantly they don't
necessarily get larger as the battery
pack its larger in fact they may get
smaller now if we get the dose i should
say the blue dot is based on assuming
that all the electricity that we get to
charge the vehicle comes from the
average source in the united states if
we were to get all of our electricity
from the cleanest possible source say a
zero emission source which is labeled
hydro on the graph then we would see
some benefits associated with larger
battery packs but it's still relatively
flat not the same kind of benefits
dramatic benefits that are shown by the
federal tax credit and it could go the
other way if we're charging our electric
vehicles from coal-fired power plants
that could result in actually increasing
damages relative to today's conventional
vehicles so the main takeaways here the
benefits are important but they're
smaller than the
a current federal tax credit the trend
does not match the policy we don't see
substantially increasing benefits
associated with larger battery packs and
to be a good value plug-in vehicles have
to be cost-competitive with their
alternatives and the vehicles that are
most cost competitive here are the ones
on the left hybrid electric vehicles and
plug-in vehicles that have a relatively
small battery pack short electric range
followed by gasoline when you take
longer trips here's another way to think
of that the current policy gives up to
75 hundred dollars per vehicle for up to
200,000 vehicles per manufacturer so
that's 1.5 billion dollars if we have
1.5 billion dollars worth of subsidies
to spend and we spent it all on
subsidizing the purchase Premium of a
hybrid electric vehicle we could buy
about 400,000 of those vehicles and we
would reduce damages by about 350
million dollars but if we were to spend
that same pool of money trying to buy
battery electric vehicles that are more
expensive we couldn't buy as many of
them and the net amount of benefits we
reproduce would be quite a bit lower the
bottom line is that hybrid electric
vehicles and plug-in vehicles with small
battery packs provide the most amount of
social benefits per dollar spent it
could be in the future that large
battery packs will become more
competitive we would need cheaper
batteries more expensive gasoline we
would need cleaner electricity and long
battery life so we're not replacing
these batteries before the end of life
and we'd have to overcome some of the
issues with range but I would argue that
even if this is the turns out to be the
future still the best way to get there
could be to focus on the vehicles that
are most competitive and provide the
most benefits now our efforts to
disseminate this information and has
included policy briefs on Capitol Hill
discussions with automakers input to the
National Petroleum Council study on
future transportation fuels requested by
the Department of Energy and some
articles in magazines and appearances in
the media and if you'd like to find out
more about this study or the other work
that we do in the vehicle
electrification group you can go to ww
see you
you edu / CIT / v EG